[Music]
what gives with you and Gabby yeah me
and Gabby are not dating she's a great
person I just met her on Dancing With
the Stars I would take her on a date one
day but she's on tour and we're not in
the same place wait you guys were never
dating never never she was engaged
during the whole time that I was on
dance with the stars has that stopped
you before me come on yeah
I'm a nice guy we have good chemistry
time maybe one thing yeah she's so
pretty she is she's a great person still
single anything else
well actually since you asked you like
him just say it you like Benny could
there ever be a Vinnie and Angelina or
is it more like a brother-sister thing
yeah um I know everybody wants that but
it's like do you want that absolutely
not are you setting the record straight
I try every day I scream it from the
rooftops we're just like a weird family
at this point yes so you sleep at your
face I know I knew that was coming
speaking of family the situation is
about to add to hits his wife Lauren is
due with a baby girl any day now what
are some of those tips that you would
give to Mike
I don't even know because our daughters
are
Satan bonds of us and saying I think
it's called karma yes it is right and
everyone always says that but we never
knew to the extent
[Music]
where are we vacating to this season
Vinnie this was like all over the place
we went everywhere I was doing Dancing
with the Stars so like a couple people
came to LA to see that
um and Mike was in a cornhole
competition in North Carolina
we're going to cornhole tournament
I would never do that is there lots of
drama
always unfortunately
on a high note with some drama so now
are y'all good with everybody
we're in Jersey Shore family vacation
premieres Thursday on MTV there will be
one noticeable absence Ronnie Ortiz
magro he only appeared briefly last
season while seeking medical treatment
for mental health issues have y'all
heard from him is he still included in
the group chats how's he doing these
days personally I haven't you talk to
him Penny
um no not really I think he just you
know still was working on himself after
he left the show yeah and um you know I
just wish him the best okay I think it's
time to play a little
bit sure
[Music]
who is the best kisser the Jersey Shore
cast ew oh how would we know that I mean
we've literally all made out can we both
agree it's Nicole since we both made out
with her oh my God I'm the best kisser I
think in this whole planet or on this
whole planet who's your celebrity Hall
Pass oh
Tom Holland really he's so cute he's
literally 25. oh my God Jason Momoa
probably like Lori Harvey I'm waiting
for her to like um like to be one of her
roster but you know she has like a new
roster like every year like I just want
her to like just use it acknowledge all
right you're watching girl who do you
think will be the next one to take a
Hiatus from the show Jenny I quit
every day you guys still Envision doing
the Heritage Shore into your 40s yeah
yeah 100 yeah Mike turned 40 this year
did either of you ever vote for anyone
else besides Vinnie on Dancing With the
Stars
[Music]
oh thank you they supported me so much I
voted yes I voted yes and online the
only one I ever did after you was
Chandra oh you did but after that but
that was after he was gone he was the
worst fashion sense on the show
made a decision and it wasn't good it
was horrible
[Music]